yeah so for those of you that don't
watch my main videos on YouTube AJ left
out a critical piece of information in
his little director's commentary video
uh he draws with a computer mouse no I'm
not kidding almost every single drawing
AJ has contributed to these drawing
videos I put on is not done on a Wacom
tablet not done on an iPad Pro none of
those sensible more professional options
he inherently just draws with a Logitech
g703 the worst part of it all though is
his re listening it's not because he has
no other option in fact not only does he
have an iPad Pro with matching apple
pencil but he also owns several 100b
display tablets right next to where he
works so no the reason he draws with a
mouse is because and these are in his
words not mine can't be bothered to plug
the tablet in